okay
so we talked about the average treatment
effect we talked about randomized
controlled trials
we've talked about why estimating
average treatment effects in randomized
trials
is very nice but we also talked about
how
not every setting in which we want to
estimate an average treatment effect
um is a randomized trial and so then our
next question is what can we do there
and so the setting i want to focus on
now
is one in which we observe some
pre-treatment covariates x
and we're worried the treatment is not
random
in that it may be associated with some
of these pre-treatment coverage
x if that's a situation then we need to
control
these axes and how best to do so
is essentially the direction we're going
in particular we're going to want to see
how does machine learning fit into all
this
now before going there though um there's
obviously a question
under which conditions is controlling
for these x's enough
under what conditions that's kind of
bringing these access to the table
help us enable us to identify an
average treatment effect where kind of
we're not in a randomized trial
and we of course need to be explicit
about that
so here the assumption i'm going to be
working with
throughout is this assumption called
uncompoundedness
whereby treatment may not be randomized
overall but once you condition on x's
treatment is as good as random
conditional on x
as i'll discuss over the next couple
slides
uh once you have this assumption
controlling for x's is enough to
identify the average treatment effect
and then that'll
set us up to focus on our main question
that is
so given that the average treatment
effect is identified
how do we estimate it
all right so
to be a little more formal about this
assumption
that is that treatment is as good as
random
given measured covariates x
what do i mean we're going to be in the
same setup as before
we have x y w's with the same
interpretation as before
potential outcomes the definition of the
average treatment defect is the same
but instead of assuming that we have a
randomized trial as before
a randomized trial right would just be
with an orange here
that is that the treatment is random
it's independent of the potential
outcomes here we're not going to assume
that
and instead um we're only going to
assume that kind of
once you condition on x's for a fixed
value of x the treatment is as good as
random
so the treatment might not be randomized
overall
but once for every fixed value of x
conditionally in x
the data looks like it comes to a
randomized trial
this assumption is also known as
selection observables
or no unmeasured confounders
what this means is that if there are any
variables
that w is associated with in a way that
makes you deviate from
other randomized trial assumptions then
you need to be able to
measure them and condition on them to
bring you
into this nice setup
one question you might have here is
just this kind of a in terms of the
nomenclature
we were worried about a confounding
problem and
here this assumption uh is referred to
as uncompoundedness
so so what's up with that um the the
point here is that
if w the treatment uh assignment
probabilities
can vary with x's then overall
you're confounded overall you don't have
the randomized trial type assumptions
but once you bring the x's to the table
once you condition on the x's then at
that point
conditionally on x you have the
treatment looks as good as random
so once you condition on x you've
reached unconfoundedness
so that's the meaning you were
confounded before but now you brought an
x
and now you've achieved unknown
so this is the assumption it's really an
important assumption i guess i felt the
need to highlight it in three different
colors
um this assumption does not hold in all
applications
for example in instrumental variables
problems you're interested in settings
where this doesn't hold but in many
settings of interest it does hold
um and the rest of this week's lectures
are going to be
on inference about the average treatment
effect
in something that's not a randomized
trial but under unconfoundedness
that is when this assumption holds
so okay we have an assumption
good we have a question
now how do we proceed how do we estimate
the average treatment effect on drowning
out of this
there are many ways to go from here and
i'm going to talk about
one approach now another function part
three the double robust approaches can
kind of combine both ideas to get some
really good
but let's start from one idea and
it's the following
um in this general uncompoundedness
setting
the average of the treated
the average treatment effect does not
match the average of y
conditional one w equals one minus the
average of y
given w equals zero uh that was the last
picture
we saw in the previous part but what you
can do
uh is just try to do a similar
derivation
but now kind of re-express what is the
average treatment effect
well we're just gonna kind of
if you uh if you've uh taken probability
classes this will make perfect sense
otherwise i hope you'll just buy that um
uh derivation you get at the end is
reasonable
we're going to kind of by chain rule at
a conditioning on x here
then kind of once we condition on x
these three lines here
are essentially the same proof as before
what they say is that conditional on x
the expected treated potential outcome
is the same
as the expected outcome condition on x
and receiving treatment and
okay i'll let you stare at the
derivation more on the side if you want
um the the end result is that
we find that the average treatment
effect can be expressed
as the expected difference between these
conditional response functions
where here mu w x is expectation of y
given x equals x w equals w
um so mu w x is kind of
the solution to the non-parametric
regression problem where we try to
predict y from x and w
and what this calculation shows is that
under unconfoundedness under this kind
of
assumption here then the average
treatment effect
is the expected difference in kind of
your best prediction given x of what
would happen to you under treatment
versus control
um if you were to kind of do these know
these
mu one of x mu zero of x functions
apriori
so this is kind of a characterization of
tau how do we turn this into an
estimation strategy
um hey at least kind of the notation
heavily suggests one
mu w of x is a non-parametric regression
problem
so you could try to solve it here
the true tau is the expectation of mu
one of x
and mu zero of x so what could we try
we could try um estimating
mu zero of x from data so here kind of
mu zero of x is the expectation of y
among controls conditional and x equals
x
so you could learn mu zero of x by
learning to predict y from x
among controls uh similarly learn mu one
of x
and then estimate tau of x
by taking the difference over your whole
data set
of these two regression functions
and kind of what i've shown so far
is that if you were to do this
using the true mu zero of x and true mu
one of x
then this would be an unbiased estimate
of the average treatment effect
and let's say it's quite clear
that this estimator will be consistent
um
for the average treatment effect if the
mu had w
uh x's are consistent with the mu w x
so consistent is good uh is okay uh but
this is actually good
does this let you get confidence
intervals and so forth
and okay here
it's it's complicated
um in order to kind of
talk about how good this strategy is
um we of course kind of
in order to kind of talk about in
general how good is this estimating the
average treatment effect
by taking the average difference in
predictions from the mu 1 of x and mu 0
x functions we need to talk about kind
of
specifically in steps one and two how
did you get these mu zero of x mu one x
estimates and here there are many
different strategies
one of them the classical one would be
to use
uh linear regression or kind of more
formally ordinarily squares
ols so
what does the ols approach do
it first starts
this is not algorithmic but it's very
important it start by
positing a linear model remember mu w
x is
measures what is the expected value of y
among
treatment status w given covariate
values x
you're doing linear regression linear
regression fits linear functions
so you're going to kind of find the
right functional shape if the linear
model is actually
correct uh well specified so we're going
to start by assuming that mu w
x is correctly specified linearly
and then once we've done this then it's
kind of clear what we can do
we can just kind of fit so mu
zero of x is x times beta zero and so
forth we can estimate
beta hat zero by just regressing y and x
among the controls
we can fit beta at one by regressing y
and x and when we're treated
uh so this is just uh very
standard and then uh once we kind of get
we can extract predictions from linear
regression as usual
and then uh what's our
of the average treatment effect well
it's just going to be the average
difference in predictions from linear
regression
as you'd expect um and
i guess you can do the algebra um this
is equivalent to just taking
the two regression parameters beta had
one and beta hat zero taking their
difference
um and interproducting that with x bar
um
that is the uh average
of the x's there's a typo here this
should be divided by
n all right so this is linear regression
is it good is it bad ah what are the
pros and cons
here is pretty clear linear regression
essentially hinges on well specification
of the linear model
in this setting what's the pro when the
linear model is well specified
this is great this is simple it's
familiar it's easy to run
it has great guarantees it converts at
parametric rate it gives you everything
you could ever want
uh what's the con well
what if the linear specification doesn't
hold but if you don't have linearity
here
then linear regression just won't give
you the right answer
so it's one of these things if kind of
the parametric assumptions you pause it
are valid
this is very good otherwise it's not
so this is linear regression um
what else can you do um i think i think
it's pretty
clear uh where i'm going with this um
is in this class we want to use machine
learning
how we want to avoid kind of assuming
that functions are linear
unless we have strong scientific reason
to do so
and so okay
an idea here is let's follow the same
strategy
except instead of assuming that the
function is mu wx
have linear specifications so you can
fit them by linear regression
let's just assume that they're generic
fit them
by machine learning and see what we get
from there
one thing i should emphasize here is
kind of last week um we talked about
machine learning
as kind of black boxes there are many
machine learning black boxes deep nets
boosted trees or random forests um the
lasso and so forth
that help you predict y from x
and here we don't
superficially we're not trying to do
prediction uh superficially
what we're trying to get is we're trying
to get at these conditional response
functions
mu w of x is expectation of y
conditional on x and w
but now um
it's just um should note
that kind of under squared error loss
what is the
optimal prediction of y given x and w
well it's just going to be
if if if you if you only know x and w
then your best prediction of y
is the expected value of y given x and w
so actually an
oracle would predict y hat
i is mu w i x i so kind of
a good predictive method should be
predicting using something that's very
close to these functions
so what we're going to assume is that we
when we train our machine learning
method
and it gets predictions then these
predictions are going to be
close to this because kind of the better
the predictive method
the closer it's going to be um to using
these functions for prediction
so um where this leaves us is
the idea is to pick our favorite machine
learning to predict y from x and w um
in general i'm going to run this
one could predict y from x separately on
the treated around the controls
or one could try to kind of fit a joint
model for both
talk more about that a couple weeks from
now
then one could use these predictions as
estimates for the functions we care
about mu zero of x and u1 of x
and then we're gonna estimate tau hat
is just the average of mu had one of x i
and you had zero
x i so just very concretely what's going
on here
mu hat one of x this the way you kind of
get it out of the machine learning
method
is you ask hey here's a person with
covariates x
i and they're treated what's your
prediction for the outcome
the machine learning method is going to
tell you this then
for the same person x i now i'm going to
tell you that they're not treated
can you predict what's health and y
going to be the machine learning method
well this is going to be the prediction
they get out
and so then tau hat is this average
difference in predictions
and really the the hope here is that
machine learning method should enable
accurate predictions without having to
model
the shape of the mu0x and mu1 of x
functions
um so it almost seems like
first uh if the machine learning methods
were just perfect
then it would almost be like a free
lunch um
you don't assume linearity but you fit
the mu 1 of x and mu 0 of x function
anyways and then you're good to go
so let's see let's see how this plays
out
so here i guess the simplest way to see
how this all plays out is just to try it
so i'm going to try to use the
regression adjustment form throughout
so all the estimators i'm going to
consider are going to have this kind of
form
and then i'm going to try two different
strategies for learning the new hats
we could get them out of linear
regression or we could get them out of
some machine learning method um this
week i'm going to use random forests
as kind of a standard method for generic
machine learning
um if we know the reason is that they're
a machine learning method and they're
very easy to run and there's very few
tuning parameters in them
so kind of they're very nice to use as
kind of reproducible examples
with that uh reason or it's not that
they don't have tuning parameters but
they
you can run them with default tuning
parameters and that's good enough for an
example
so all right these are the two
uh basic settings and then i'm going to
talk about them
in two different simulation uh studies
one where these kind of response
functions uh
the expectation of y given x among the
treated and controls separately
one where they're linear so linear
regression is well specified linear
regression is justified
and one where they're not linear so
linear regression
has an incorrect specification
and how does this work so here
i just in the slides kind of very
briefly this is how
you'd actually get tau hat out of linear
regression
i'm not going to go through this in
detail but just
uh in case you wanted to run this and
wanted to copy paste some code
here's on the slide similarly here is
using a random forest
um similar thing
um here kind of very explicitly we're
getting these kind of
mu has zero uh muhaft ones out of here
and our estimate of the average
treatment effect is going to be the
average difference in predictions
all right and
what settings are we going to look at
well just like i mentioned
we're going to look at a linear setting
this is
and by linear i mean that
y responds to x
in a linear way the linear function may
be different among treated and control
groups
notice this is normal noise with mean 0
and variance 4.
then the nonlinear setting looks similar
except here now the relationship between
y and x
is not linear there's a step function in
here there's a quadratic
linear regression won't capture that
correctly
so what's going to happen
well for linear regression it's
probably should be uh familiar what's
going to happen um
i'm changing the sample size here so
here and as a sample size
at the low end we have 100 units to
estimate the average treatment effect
at the upper end we have 1600
and what happens here first
what i'm showing here is a box plot and
this box plot
shows the realization of the average
treatment effect you get
across multiple simulations so the first
thing to notice is that kind of
regardless of the sample size
the box plot is always centered the
treatment the average treatment effect
estimate you get by linear regression
is unbiased um
this is this is good um as you'd hoped
this is kind of and what else happens
when you get more data
well you're always unbiased so that's
not something you're solving
but the other thing that happens is kind
of the
box plots narrow you're getting more
accurate
so kind of with 100 samples you're right
on average but you're very wrong in most
replications
whereas with 1600 samples you write on
average and also you're pretty
close to the truth uh most of the time
so
this is what you like to see what
happens in the non-linear setting where
linear regression is misspecified
well some things look like before linear
regression
is going to have the same average answer
kind of regardless of the sample size
it's going to give you that answer more
and more accurately as you collect more
data
but what's your problem your problem is
that the
average answer of linear regression
isn't equal to
the true answer so here kind of
um the true average treatment effect was
zero
uh so here's the dashed line you would
have wanted to get zero here you got
zero on average
uh whereas here you did not get zero on
average and
yeah so this kind of shows that linear
regression kind of
as you collect more and more data if the
linear specification isn't right
uh it's hopeless right you just won't
get the right answer
so what about random forests um
here is actually very interesting um
it's a completely different picture now
first the thing is remember here zero is
the correct answer
as you collect more data
you get closer to the correct answer in
both settings
so both in the linear setting and in the
nonlinear setting
you're converging to the right answer
but and here's the
big uh problem issue
one needs to deal with um we don't have
this setting like linear regression
where kind of when you're well specified
not only are you getting more accurate
but kind of even finite samples you're
unbiased
here you're always converting to the
right answer
but in finite examples you may be very
biased
here in the linear setting we see that
kind of for all sample sizes i'm looking
at
the point estimates for the average
treatment effect here are kind of
strongly kind of systematically
biased upwards um we have a
they're not symmetrical around zero at
all um here in the non-linear setting
it's interesting
for large sample sizes the treatment
effects
are kind of better centered at the right
answer but for small samples you also
work on a very biased
so this is going to be
uh a problem
um as as as we're going to see in kind
of subsequent parts
really the reason this is the problem if
all you cared about is getting the right
answer
in very large samples this wouldn't be a
problem like i said
uh random forests are gonna get you here
consistency what consistency means is
that in the limit of infinite data
you're gonna get the right answer
but often when you're running this you
care about more than consistency you
want to get a good rate of convergence
you want to use your data effectively
and you want to get confidence intervals
that kind of even in moderate samples
cover um
the truth um and in the problem uh with
with nominal probability
and the issue is kind of when you have
these kinds of very biased estimators
it's essentially they're not going to
have good rates of convergence and
it's essentially hopeless to get
confidence intervals
at least using standard constructions so
that's an issue what's the trade-off
between linear regression
and random forests uh linear regression
bits on everything being linear
if this assumption is valid you get
unbiasedness
i haven't shown constructions for
confidence intervals yet but
kind of the fact that linear regression
is unbiased is closely related to the
fact that confidence intervals
all work here so
all right if the linear linearity
assumption is valid
everything worked perfectly with linear
regression if it
fails everything goes out the window
there's nothing to do
um and this gets us into kind of
a setting that might be quite familiar
from econometric classes right you like
think very hard about fitting a
parametric model
and once you've picked the right
parametric model then estimation is easy
but machine learning it really puts you
in a different world
linear regression kind of depending on
whether you wrote the right model down
you're
either essentially doing the right thing
or the wrong thing but with random
forests
you're kind of never quite wrong but
you're never quite right either
um you're never quite wrong in that
you're always going to get the large
right answer with infinite data but
you're generally going to get there in a
way that's kind of
rather slow and
in order to get
accurate estimates of the average
treatment effect that use the data
effectively or to build confidence
intervals
um you're going to have to do something
about this